hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to Emporium now I wanted to
warn you guys before we get into this
this game apparently covers themes of
suicide and maybe even darker subjects
so I just wanted to warn you guys before
getting into it because this will
probably get dark and it will probably
get sad so I don't know what to expect
about it because apparently it's some
sort of artistic look at it analogies
for personhood for the self for
consciousness
exert great power honor thinking and to
think of consciousness as a locked
chamber to think of the contents of a
chamber as perception that will thus
seem lose any loose stably private to
think of our experiencing of the world
as hidden but hidden inwardly
ineluctably ineluctably private I've
never heard of that word I have a pretty
extensive vocabulary but I have never
heard of ineluctably okay something some
waiting for me huh
oh okay
Oh
okay oh I'm moving alrighty then
well yep wander right into Emporium this
seems like a good idea okay I don't know
I'm going in here but all right did I
just fall from the roof why was i lying
bloody in the middle of the row Kay hi
hell is this oh my god it's so crazy
this place oh hi there can you help me
understand what the hell's going on here
because I seem to be missing something
here hey buddy how's it going how you
doing the boy did nothing just looked up
at me there was a flicker of recognition
and I felt like a time traveller
he seemed unsure of what to say next I
met my father only once where my mother
raised me poorly I don't know I don't
know is this important I don't know I
met my father only once he spoke rapidly
now fantasy stories of superhero dads I
think that's what I meant
I knew them to be mostly untrue but
choose chose to believe regardless okay
I don't know if I want to go in that
trailer sir
oh that's all right you know what I'm
gonna go anyway
oh my god this game is so weird and I
love it like I love it
it's weird but he's cool I am
shipwrecked this morning folded over
into sorry waves water water everywhere
why am I here what the RV it was just a
piece of cardboard
oh okay I'm folded out onto the waves of
the ocean we're suddenly playing raft
again oh do I need to declare my
loneliness to the world oh boy oh boy oh
boy oh boy oh hi there you are I didn't
even see you there
I found myself busy in whispers with
some kind of ocean I didn't notice the
boy by my side staring out counting the
waves in a rushed fluster the boy tugged
my sleeve and beckoned my ear closer
a child is only a child once or I'd like
to try and drown oh I wouldn't like to
try that that's like one of my worst
ways that I could possibly die I'll go
with a child is only a child once thank
you the boy spoke of a newly hatched egg
did I the babe featherless breathless
and still lost in some rotten tumble a
gyeom individuals on this are really
really cool
[Music]
I don't know what else you want from me
okay
I guess I'll go back can I go back now
lotta DeeDee doodle
okay that's uh that's a big building
that's a big building that's a big
building that is a big building popped
up out of nowhere as a big building oh
hi
okay climbing climb we go I don't know
why we're here and I don't know who put
it here
oh it's uncomfortable boo hi okay hello
someone in there why would someone be in
there oh hi oh don't look at me like
that
oh don't do that to me oh don't look at
me like that I was left in the company
of my father for a single day I don't
believe he spoke at all he just walked
along that pier and held my hand while I
toddled in tow the impossible depth of
that green gray water is all I remember
clearly so that has to do with the
choice I made in the beginning of the
game I think I'm pretty sure that would
have changed I don't know if there's
multiple endings to this I have no idea
I don't know the ramifications of these
decisions but I'm so curious and also
not curious because I'm not sure I want
to know who where this is leading me to
higher and higher I go in this tower in
the middle of nowhere through halls that
I can't control
Oh okay I'm back here but now there's a
birdhouse I think I understand the
analogy that fly free pretty little
birdy oh boy
wait are we just starting over again do
I have to make all the choices do I have
to make the right choices here I don't
know I'm not sure what's with the
birdhouse okay why is there an Emporium
hello birdie birdie the nesting box was
no longer a home I placed it here so the
boy could listen for himself that never
ending inconsolable cry emanating from
such a tiny hole powered by impossible
acoustics okay all right good reminder
thank you for that I think thank you
thank you for that if we go in here and
I have to make different choices I'll do
that but I don't ah this is different
that wasn't a trolley car there and
there was no kitchen over there I have
no idea what this is
was I supposed to be looking at oh hi oh
the plaque red hiding place number eight
or dinner with mother oh I didn't know
that these were exhibits that I was
supposed to look at the plaque red
hiding place
number 443 or stationary 143 how many
places do you need why do you need so
many hiding places what is happening the
plaque red hiding place number zero zero
Oh alrighty then well I can't go ok
alright well camera is going funky on me
the plaque red hiding place number six
or wooden masks okay so I'm gonna talk
to the guy again but this is definitely
different right I'm not crazy here it's
different I think I don't know I tried
to remember what it was like to be young
perhaps the boy would remind me
perhaps it would make a difference oh I
can think myself invisible being alone
is part of survival I should I kind of
disagree with one of those but I don't
think I can think myself invisible but
that has that like relates to all the
hiding places I guess kind of in a way
the boys voice deepened now he spoke
slow low and quiet his words came at me
as if from inside my own chest and as
they did I swear I saw him blur around
the edges okay that's weird
yeah okay I'll step into your weird RV
home I'm sure nothing horrible is gonna
happen
my gonna waking up here again or am I
gonna go somewhere else
I had a heady notion to flee the
sensation had come fast and I found it
intoxicating
I needed to vanish and have the void
left in my wake shrink up behind me oh
this is different
okay well there's the trolley car what
is all this
it's so weird I've never really seen a
game told from this perspective before
just let alone like the isometric view
of it but from such a distance shot to
like it's it's really really cool
oops almost missed my target there what
the hell happened over there I mean I
know none of this is actual reality here
but boy I once leant on this bridge
ready to take myself over its barrier
hoping for one of the ancient
locomotives to rattle forth and run me
through oh I had waited a lifetime
before I realized all the trains had
stopped running it was in this waiting
that I first met the boy anything can
crumble in an instant or to be still is
to be peaceful
that sounds moderately Pleasant I guess
but also I kind of believe this one
anything can crumble in an instant
I don't know I'll go with the peaceful
one the boy regaled me with our travels
and commutes that kinetic score of steam
and metal how we wished for silence to
be grave and Static oh wait unless you
meant like to be still as oh ok that's
alright then alrighty then I'll be on my
way unless you meant to be still is to
be peaceful as in death that's not as
nice as I might have thought that it
would be anything can crumble in an
instant just as the same as any trains
can just fly off into the sky and then
be lost to the void I have no idea
what's happening ok further up we go I
guess unless is the exact same way to go
and then honestly who knows hello do you
have some mysteries to unfold for me oh
don't look at me like that I still don't
like it
this compared to the last one I don't
think I like it I have a superpower that
no one else knows about I discovered
this when I was six years old is it to
be invisible I would let my breathing
shallow and keep myself perfectly still
before I knew it I would fade into
something almost like water and seep
through every crack in the earth
I don't know what that means and I don't
know how useful that superpower is that
seems seems weird and I metaphorical
even oh we're still going up we didn't
get sent out into the abyss oh okay
unless I didn't get set out into the
abyss before I don't remember okay I
remember are we going back are we gonna
go back do we have to go back I don't
know I don't know anything
oh we're back now oh good
ah yes we have a new exhibit is there
gonna be something poetic about that one
to God it seems like if I had to guess
what's going on here
this guy is looping through his life
after he threw himself on the roof of
this building
whatever this building is like that
splotch of blood on the ground is where
he'll land I had to build a shrine to
monotony there is a calm to be found in
repetition so I would busy myself in
busy little circles until sick from the
spin now great is that like an easter
egg am I supposed to dizzy myself in in
sweet circles until I'm sick from the
spin because I could do that gonna give
it one more loop and
I'm out of here ah all right I'm gone
whoosh whoosh key here we are back in
the lovely Emporium the building of epic
proportions okay so the kitchen is the
same this is different and that exhibit
up there the plaque reads hiding-place
number 56 or head-office
right I don't know where the head office
is located oh hello how are you doing
the plaque reads hiding place number 23
or mr. invisible not very invent I see
you sorry to burst your bubble sorry to
burst anything here hello
you want to talk to me again give me
some more choices that I don't
understand the boy looked ready for
battle
do I his eyes darted holding only two
still me with a vicious Blair Hirst and
tense the boy seemed violent like never
before we can live forever are we going
to die
one's not true are we going to die the
boy cried loud and angry I could offer
no comfort or reason we are unfortunates
without escape ok
all right whatever you say I'll go on my
way now what's happening no trying to
make sense of his every hoard click and
clack is tattooed across my body every
smell runs thick is oil down my arms and
fingers I am poisoned by industry and at
mercy to that Bend of fleshy iron no
know where I am now this doesn't seem
like bending fleshie iron okay
oh nice chair oh you're talking about
slaving away your life in cubicles
amazed ah okay I don't get it oh boy ha
ha ha I mean I do get it I'm not saying
I'm completely lost here I do get it
it's like categorical of this guy's life
I wouldn't be surprised if this old man
because like turned out to be this boy
this is ridicule I told the boy this
errant machine requires constant
attention no more will we mend and
maintain let it turn to rust the bones
will scatter under their own weight let
it carry you abandon everything well
that seems pretty grim I'm gonna go with
the not quite so positive but possibly
more meaningful let it carry you the boy
heard it too
that melodic automation of gears and
guts he urged me to engage to find peace
in that rhythmic human whisper okay oh
hi what hi hello hi your long
you're a long boy okay alright then I'm
gonna just enter the tip here I guess
nothing weird about this one
okay I okay back up we go then I guess
I'm going up and here we go is there
like some other outcome to this if you
pick different choices do they all lead
to the same place or do they all have
branching paths do they all infect the
story in different ways I don't know and
why are you in that room alone why are
you sitting what does it mean
I am tired now I feel this body built
around me expanding before long I'm sure
I won't be able to see the walls of it
and I will echo into silence okay
okay alrighty then thank you
alright I'm gonna go up now I don't know
how many loops I'm supposed to make here
it's all just obscure poetry at this
point with some deeper meaning hidden in
and I know I know there's a deeper
meaning hitting here or maybe it's
pretty blatant on its surface oh there I
am again there I am again ah what is
that that an iron lung said an iron lung
an iron lung is like a horrifying device
that helped people breathe this was a
gift from the boy to me
a breath a life inevitably
I chose to ignore it yep that's an iron
lung I don't know why there's an iron
lung there I'm not on represent sure why
anything's here and I really hope I
don't have to fill every parking space
on this bad boy because that will take a
whoa it's empty why is it empty where'd
he go okay I miss him now where'd he go
where'd he go where did he go where did
he go I don't know my life was built
brittle as if wooden a simple toy
without a full set what remains will
fragment perfect perfect perfect perfect
perfect little perfect perfect little
perfect
what
oh okay I don't know what this is
[Music]
hello I'm here now I will go upstairs I
think
[Music]
mother is that you up there oh the boys
searched for me without luck he did
however find where I was keeping her a
wife in Rouen and mother to a ghost
he spoke aloud knowing I would hear she
is strong or you were weak but it was
you strong too strong
my wife's perseverance was enough to
bring us both through she became mother
like to me why did I resent this
no not resentment I was a burden a
parasite held in embrace I don't know if
that's true
hey wait don't close on me don't close
on me oh hi we're floating now
apparently Oh we're falling now
apparently
oh I can't control this Oh No gentle
caress ah okay I have no idea where I am
now is this what we might call the
afterlife oh my god
that's so weird oh man it's weird
oh there I go okay I thought it was
gonna okay there I go okay we're fine
everything's fine I'm just gonna go get
my balloon okay
No
I thought he was gonna throw himself
from the top of the stairs no no no no
you do oh don't give me with that
mannequin [ __ ] don't do that don't do
that oh man okay I think like the old
man might be the father now and why
there's so many mom mannequins mom
Atkins why there's so many of them hello
mama
nothing explain anything to me no okay
I'll just head inside mom thanks thanks
mama
thank you for that oh boy oh [ __ ] it's
the hiding place has finally opened up
oh and there's a lovely cloud duvet in
the back good for me I suppose oh where
am I now
oh no
Oh No I got a bad feeling about this one
this one seems okay got bad feeling
about this one
Oh No oh no I think I know what's about
to happen oh I think I know what's about
to happen oh don't do it don't do it
Oh Oh No okay not so bad
oh no no
Oh No Oh No
I'm like marching towards the precipice
as if it's the only option but obviously
it is there's nothing else there
there's no getting up this time
the Emporium seemed most fitting nearby
retail expansions have left both my
business and the building derelict I too
often take my lunch on the roof during
slow and sunny days a quiet spot where
no one would notice me yes the Emporium
seemed most fitting I let my fingers and
feet go numb as I wish the boy farewell
I think oh I think the the story is more
apparent towards the ending there it's
at its heart it's about someone running
away and trying to hide like talking
about the boys if the boy was a
different person and the old man
probably being the father I don't know
it's obvious there's not different
endings to that one that's a mess you up
kinda game
that's a mess you up kind of game anyway
whenever I play a game like this that
touches on a very serious subject I
always want to make sure at the end of
it that I remind you guys that suicide
is never the answer
it's you know there's as many cliches as
you could say about it as you want but
it's
it's awful I I I'm I'm not I'm not
intending to take this time to be as
profound as I could be
or try to be but in this moment it's
it's something to remember that if you
are ever thinking of taking your own
life there are people that want to help
you and there's people that want to know
you and there's people that want to be
there for you and I think it's it's it's
a really really important thing that
we've touched on before for subjects of
depression and subjects of suicide where
it's just heartbreak and III would
actively encourage anyone that is having
dark thoughts or going through rough
times to reach out and seek help not
only in just in this community alone and
there are many resources in here but
there's also resources out there we've
done charity events for the depression
and bipolar support alliance and and
crisis text line and I am and various
different charities for this but just
from one person to another I
I would ask you to hold on and stay
strong and keep fighting
whatever the demons that you're fighting
and I can know them because I haven't
experienced them in the way that you
have but that's all I is it you stay
strong and reach out so anyway I'll
leave it at that I'll try I'm not I know
I don't want to come across as preachy
especially when it comes to something
like this but that's that's thank you
everybody so much for watching
reach out to someone down the comments
below reach out to someone else in the
community somewhere else and then reach
out to those resources that I've talked
about and there's even more and I'm sure
people can list more down the column so
thank you everybody so much for watching
thank you to the creator of this game
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye